The townsfolk scream and run in terror, their
flaming torches and pitchforks falling from
their trembling hands.
Behind them, SCP-096 roars in monstrous rage.
It will kill every single one of them.
And to think, this had been the happiest few
weeks of its life not long before…
SCP-096 is one of the most fearsome anomalies
ever contained by the SCP Foundation.
Responsible for nearly as many containment
breaches and personnel casualties as SCP-682,
the Shy Guy is known for only a few things:
its long, pale limbs, its tendency to huddle
in the corner of its cell, weeping, and the
fact that anyone who sees its face is doomed
to meet a horrible, violent fate.
Most of the researchers and civilians alike
who have crossed SCP-096's past would have
no trouble describing it as a monster, and
some might even use stronger language than
that.
But, though SCP-096 is certainly frightening
to behold, and often deadly to those who behold
all of it, the Shy Guy is not a monster, not
to everyone.
Once upon a time, it even had a friend.
Many, many years ago, before the SCP Foundation
first contained SCP-096, it was just a pale
figure that hid from sight in the dense, snowy
forest on a remote mountainside.
There, its long, lanky body and unnaturally
pale complexion allowed the creature to blend
in with the landscape, skin like snow and
arms and legs like branches and slender tree
trunks.
No one ever came into its domain, save for
the occasional lost hiker, and it was easy
enough for the Shy Guy to duck out of sight
when they did come.
In the warmer months, crews of lumberjacks
would come through, and the Shy Guy would
have to be more careful with its hiding, moving
quickly to keep its face obscured from the
strangers.
None of them ever saw its face, though they
could feel its presence.
They would whisper amongst themselves about
the feeling of being watched, recalling old
lumberjack legends of "the hidebehind," a
creature that stalked through forests and
hid itself behind the trees whenever its prey
turned to look.
The Shy Guy wasn't trying to hunt them, it
only wanted to be left alone, but the lumberjacks
still glanced over their shoulders nervously
as they went about their work, swapping scary
stories around the campfire at night when
the work was done.
But other than a rustling branch, a flash
of white darting between the trees, or the
occasional set of unnaturally large footprints
in the snow, they never saw the creature they
could sense sharing the woods with them.
It was for the best that they didn't, they
wouldn't have survived if they had managed
to catch a glimpse of its face.
The Shy Guy was happy with its home, or at
least as happy as it could be about anything
in its life.
It was a lonely existence, never letting anyone
truly see it.
The creature's life was ruled by fear and
isolation, the terror that one day its face
would be spotted and it would be unable to
control what it did next.
Late at night, when the world was asleep save
for a few owls nestled in the branches up
above and scanning the ground for mice to
eat, the Shy Guy would let itself truly feel
the weight of its suffering, crying so hard
its sobs shook the treeline.
But other times, when the land was still and
quiet, when a fresh snowfall blanketed the
earth in soft, white powder and all living
things were hiding in a warm place until springtime
came, SCP-096 felt something like peace.
The dead of Winter was its safest time, a
time when it wouldn't need to listen for every
sound and await potential intruders.
But, of course, Winter never lasted.
Eventually, Spring would always come.
The first blades of green grass would poke
up through the melting snow, and life would
return to the Shy Guy's forest.
One day, the Shy Guy's guard dropped, and
it made a grave mistake.
It allowed someone to get too close before
looking for a hiding spot.
A man, from one of the lumber camps setting
up nearby, saw the creature's face.
The man screamed in shock and terror, but
his screams were soon drowned out by the raw,
animalistic bellow of the Shy Guy as it flew
into an uncontrollable frenzy of rage and
despair, chasing the man through the forest
at breakneck speed.
It was far faster than the man, running on
longer, stronger legs than any human could
have.
When it caught up to the man, in a foreign
part of the forest that the creature had not
seen before, it silenced his screams for good.
All at once, the creature was alone once more.
Then came the remorse, the inevitable feeling
of deep, devastating loss that came over it
every time it destroyed a person who had seen
its face.
The same cycle, over and over again, relentless
and unceasing.
Though it should have gotten used to the whole
thing by now, it broke the poor creature's
heart.
Succumbing to the sadness, SCP-096 slumped
to the ground, cradling its head in its massive
hands, and began to cry.
"Are you alright, there?
Are you hurt?"
A voice suddenly interrupted the creature's
private lament.
It froze at the sound, before lifting its
head to seek out the source of the interruption.
Who was that?
Where were they?
Did it have time to hide before they could
see its face?
The Shy Guy opened its eyes to see an old
man standing only a few feet away from it,
holding a cane.
The man was facing it, his eyes aimed toward
the Shy Guy's face, but they were unfocused.
They could not see.
The Shy Guy didn't entirely understand how,
but it knew that the man was unable to see
its face.
For the first time in a very long time, it
felt relief wash over it.
"You stopped crying.
Can you speak?"
The man walked closer to the creature, concern
furrowing his brow.
"Here, take my hand and come inside where
it's warm.
I'll get you a blanket and something to eat."
The old man held out his hand expectantly,
and slowly, hesitantly, SCP-096 placed its
hand in his.
"My, you're a big fellow!
If you can stand, come with me.
We'll get you all sorted out."
Unsure, but too surprised to do anything else,
the Shy Guy silently followed the old blind
man into a nearby cabin.
Inside, it was indeed warm, the small yet
pleasant space lit by a crackling fire in
the hearth.
It was the nicest place SCP-096 had ever been,
cozy and dry, no snow or mud to be found.
Every surface was smooth or soft, made for
living comfortably.
The old man led the creature to a little dining
table, and pulled out a chair, inviting it
to sit down.
He prattled on about how nice it was to have
some company for once, even if his new companion
was unable to speak.
He had plenty to say, and was happy to fill
the silence enough for the both of them.
He turned on a radio, and it came to life
with the sound of music and crackling static,
then he busied himself at the wood fire stove
where a pot of soup was simmering.
He poured two bowls of soup, one for him,
and one for the Shy Guy, and placed them both
on the table.
SCP-096 wasn't sure what to make of the cabin,
the soup, or the spoon that the old man handed
it to go with the meal.
After a moment of watching the old man eat,
however, it began to understand that this
was food.
It disregarded the spoon in favor of picking
up the bowl, drinking straight from it.
The broth, meat, and vegetables warmed the
creature from the inside out in a way it had
never felt before, and for once the Shy Guy
made a sound other than a screech or a sob.
"Mm!"
The old man laughed delightedly, and agreed
that the soup was indeed very good.
The two ate the rest of their meal, and the
old man placed a heavy blanket on the couch
for the creature, inviting it to stay the
night.
In fact, it could stay as long as it wanted.
Like he had said, the old man could really
use the company, as well as an extra pair
of hands to help out around the house.
This could, he said, be an arrangement that
benefitted them both!
With that, the old man went to bed, leaving
the Shy Guy alone for the night.
It considered leaving while the man slept,
slinking back off into the forest and disappearing,
but as it pulled the blanket over its body,
it felt a sense of warmth and comfort enveloping
it.
This was a safe place, one where no one would
catch it unawares and look at its face.
Maybe it could stay, at least for a little
while.
Before long, the Shy Guy's eyes closed, and
it drifted off to sleep.
The Shy Guy and the old man quickly fell into
a routine from there.
The old man taught the creature how to tidy
up around the cabin, how to chop wood and
use it to keep the stove and fireplace lit.
He showed it how to open cans of beans and
retrieve meat from the cabin's smokehouse
so they could fix their meals, and introduced
the creature to all of his favorite stations
on the radio.
All the while, the old man talked, telling
the creature stories of his life: his time
in the army, how he met his wife, how it felt
to lose her, how difficult it was to raise
his children alone, and how rewarding it was
to see them go off and start families of their
own.
During one of these stories, the old man remarked
that his family would be coming out to visit
soon, and bring him some supplies to help
him through the rest of winter before the
warm weather returned.
The Shy Guy should have understood what that
meant, should have planned to leave before
the man's family arrived, but it was so overwhelmed
by the joys of its new life that it didn't
even consider the possibility.
In this moment, it seemed that things would
always be perfect.
One morning, the Shy Guy awoke to the sound
of a knock at the door.
It jolted awake at the sound, gasping with
fear.
The Old Man rushed into the room, grinning
excitedly.
He told the Shy Guy not to be afraid, that
this was only his son coming to visit.
But SCP-096 panicked.
It had to cover its face!
Now!
As the old man opened the door to welcome
his son inside, the Shy Guy quickly buried
its face in its hands, shielding it from the
young man's eyes.
Though the young man did not doom himself
by seeing the creature's face, he couldn't
help but cry out in shock at the sight of
his father's houseguest.
He tried to explain to his father that this
was not an ordinary man in need of shelter,
but rather some sort of terrible monster.
He described the Shy Guy to his father, its
lack of clothing, its emaciated form, and
impossible height, but the old man would not
listen to a word.
He shooed his son out of the cabin, insisting
that if he was going to be rude to his guest,
then he could go ahead and see himself out.
He told his son that the Shy Guy, no matter
how strange it might look, had been a great
help and comfort to him, and he would not
tolerate a rude word against his new friend.
He slammed the door shut, then apologized
to SCP-096 for his son's behavior.
Meanwhile, his son was distraught.
His poor father, living alone with a monster!
He could not sit idly by while this continued.
He rushed into town, and told everyone all
about what he had seen.
Local lumberjacks spoke up with their own
stories, telling him about the legends of
the Hidebehind, and the lumberjack who had
gone out on a job in those woods and never
returned home.
This creature living with the old man had
to be the same monster!
The townspeople decided that enough was enough,
and they were going to take back the forest,
and handle this monster problem once and for
all.
They grabbed whatever weapons they could find,
from hunting rifles and kitchen knives to
pitchforks and torches.
All the while, they worked themselves up into
a frenzy of fear and anger.
Before long, the once-peaceful people of the
town had formed into an angry mob, with the
old man's son at the helm.
"Kill the Monster!"
They cheered, as they stormed into the forest
and toward the old man's cabin.
The old man opened his door, expecting to
find his son standing there again, and was
greeted instead by everyone from his town,
armed to the teeth and ready for a fight.
They demanded to see the Monster that he was
keeping inside.
When he refused, a group of men grabbed him
by the arms, dragging him out of the cabin.
As he protested, they insisted that they were
doing this for his own good, to protect him
from the hideous beast he had unknowingly
welcomed into his home.
He struggled to break free, but he was not
as strong as he had been in his youth, and
he was outnumbered.
SCP-096 watched as its friend was pulled from
the cabin and taken outside, and it was unable
to stop itself from intervening.
It ran out of the front door, where the angry
mob was waiting.
Neither SCP-096 nor the mob were prepared
for what happened next, when the dozens of
people standing there with their pitchforks
and torches all found their eyes locked directly
onto SCP-096's face.
The creature had been upset before, but now
it was positively furious.
Its mouth stretched into a shriek that echoed
off the mountainside, and it began to rip
through the crowd like tissue paper, massive
arms swinging and knocking over people left
and right until no one was left standing.
Some of the townspeople tried to fight back,
to prod at the creature with their pitchforks
or swipe at it with the flames of their torches,
but the attacks didn't even slow the Shy Guy
down.
Bullets fired from the feet of hunting rifles
ricocheted off of the creature's skin, not
leaving so much as a dent as it tore the crowd
apart.
By the time it was through, there was no one
left except for the old man and his son.
The old man called out to the creature, asking
what had happened, asking if it was alright.
But, as always, the creature could not answer.
And even if it could, it wouldn't have said
a word at that moment.
Its focus was elsewhere, its eyes trained
on the old man's son, the only person who
had seen its face and was still alive.
The young man ran off into the forest as fast
as he could, tripping over his own feet as
the terror made him too clumsy to see straight.
The attempt to escape was in vain, and the
Shy Guy took no time at all to catch up with
him.
It grabbed the young man in its hands, lifted
him into the air as he squirmed and fought
to break free.
Then, it unhinged its jaw, and swallowed him
whole.
When the Shy Guy quieted, all of its prey
disposed of, it heard the voice of the old
man in the distance, calling out for his friend.
It knew, then, that it could never go back
to the only person who had ever shown it kindness.
It would not be safe, for either of them.
Instead, it would return to the deep, deep
forest, to the life of solitude.
But it would never forget that time in the
cabin, or the only man who ever made SCP-096
feel as if it wasn't a monster at all.
Now go check out “SCP-096 VS Siren Head”
and “SCP-096’s Sad END!” for more!